[Music]
I'm Chris Brian and this week we're
talking about position and the
importance of position in Aikido in
Aikido practice in the modern era we
really tend to put a huge emphasis on
technique and form I think that's a real
problem in the Aikido the way we're
doing it now and so we need to
understand that something like position
is significantly more important than
technique and technique actually
facilitates better position instead of
the other way around I think in Aikido
we tend to think that the technique is
what we're trying to do and so we get to
a position just as you enable us to do a
technique but that's not true the
technique is what allows us to keep or
maintain a position that we're in so we
talked last video about he throw me the
side by side position this time we're
gonna talk about Edie me and what the et
me position is and I get Josh over here
we're gonna go to work Josh okay so
we're gonna talk a little bit about the
EDB position eating any position is the
best position for us to have the reason
is because he has the least defense and
offensive if I have an eating me
position and he's probably always trying
to get eating any position on me which
is what I'm gonna have to depend from so
the best way to get out of being eating
meat is to distance now understand if
he's attacking me when we're falling
like yeah Aikido philosophy which is I
don't want to hurt this guy if he
chooses to distance that's a winner
right so the second key feels like oh
this guy might get et me I need to
distance that's great if he distance is
perfect because distancing is better for
me than position right so on our
strategical set of things distancing is
better than positioning right so I'd
rather have more distance because it's
harder for him to hurt me with that
distance so if he chooses the distance
that's fantastic if I can and he's
trying to get eating me on me I'm going
to distance right so it all just depends
on who's getting to what position first
but if I can't make distance I'm gonna
try to stick to my eating knee position
so eating the position is
yes right so it's me coming right behind
this guy here's our eating me position
now the reason this position is so good
is because Josh could hit me as hard as
he wants from this position and he's
gonna have a real hard time hitting me
with any real force right so gonna be
very hard for him to hit me successfully
now notice what he starts to want to do
if I let him he'll turn around and hit
me now I don't have any me anymore so if
he's able to get to there he can hit me
hard but if we stay just in this
position he can't hit me very hard right
his kicks is everything gonna all be
kind of poor right so not a very strong
position meanwhile I can hit him and
grab him with all of my force right I
can hit him full force Amy and full fur
I knew everything to him full force so
if I got this position I'm starting to
win the position war I've won the
position war okay now understand again
dynamics so he's not gonna let me have
this he's gonna immediately try to do
stuff he's gonna turn around just like
that that's what he's gonna be up to so
he's gonna be turning so when he turns
what I want to try and do is redeem II
so as it turns i ET me freeze good now
right here notice I've kept my IDI me
got wit from IET me to a chocolatini
but notice I'm still in the IDI me
position here which is great now in
Aikido every time he tries to turn I try
to D me and that's what I'm trying to do
now notice what he did he got clever
there he knew that I was it any so he
distanced now I should let him distance
if he wants to do that that's fantastic
so watch what happens so let's say Josh
just turns and I eating me okay no look
I kept eating me so what's Josh gonna do
he's gonna go wider this time ah now
look you got distance but look where he
put us winner I like that that's good
for me right so he gets clever in
distance I shouldn't try to eat that
distance back up because my eating is
less important strategically than my uh
distancing right so if he wants to
distance on me so I don't get evening me
perfect right remember that's always
good but from this he's trying to stay
type to me and turn around I'm always
eating me now this gives us classic
eating me noggin right so let's say
we're here in this position Josh turns
an IV eating you mean he turns a tie
you see eventually can't meet you Rimi
because um I'm turning and keeping right
with him so I'm cutting off that side
every single time he does it and that's
what a classic eating me nog is it's not
some big clothesline it's just me
constantly keeping that rear position
and in trying to turn tighter and
tighter now in Aikido when you're trying
to do the forms you'll feel like this is
a real problem that he's doing that
because what he'll do is he'll distance
so you can't get the enemy nage if
you're stuck to doing the eating me
nugget then you're trying to catch up to
him so you can throw him for some reason
who cares about throwing him if he wants
to distance let in distance that's fine
so classic eating me knocking happens
because he's turning tight so if
Joshua's here behind me and I'm trying
to get out of here right what am I gonna
do I'm gonna try to turn as tight as I
can in here to get this guy that's what
I'm looking for now if he enters behind
me when I do that you see he just got
into a better position so he's improving
improving improving his position now if
I distance from that so if we're here
like this and as I feel that I feel he's
gonna get behind me and so what I do is
I go up further that's fine because what
he does is he starts getting more and
more distance and that's what he wants
is that distance so that's how we're
managing the eating me position and how
the techniques arise to manage that
eating me position I'm Christopher Hine
thanks for watching
[Music]